[MUSIC PLAYING]
Yeah.
[BLEEP]
[CHUCKLING]
From here, it's hard
to tell the scale.
Yeah, it's so--
it's so big.
WILL GADD: If you aren't scared
walking into Helmcken Falls,
something is wrong with you.
Imagine a covered
sports stadium.
And you cut it in half.
And coming out of the
ceiling, there's a waterfall.
And it hits the ground, sprays
all over everything behind it.
At the bottom, there's this
giant caldron out of ice.
We called it the
caldron of doom.
And if you went into
the caldron of doom,
they aren't ever
going to find you.
SARAH HUENIKEN: There's this
huge cliff with thousands
of big hanging icicles.
These are falling.
It's an ever
changing environment.
WILL GADD: You have freezing
mist on you continually.
It's the most
complicated environment
I've ever been in in my life.
MAN: Helmcken Falls is
outrageously difficult.
Just the physical act
of climbing in that kind
of terrain, it's akin to
doing hundreds of pull-ups,
but also doing a
highly choreographed
ballet at the same time.
No one's ever tried or climbed
a route of this scale before.
WILL GADD: The first time
I went to Helmcken Falls,
I saw this line.
But it was probably
about 10 years
of climbing all over the
world and a half dozen
other trips to Helmcken
to make that climb happen.
The idea was to do a line
from the bottom of the falls
to the top of the
falls, take the path of,
like, steepest
maximum resistance.
And I wanted it to be
kind of the culmination
of my ice and mixed career.
MAN: The hammer and
the ratchet I just
put on the sternal
attachment to the harness.
MAN: To do a first
ascent on something
like Helmcken Falls
requires a ton of work
because you have to
establish the route.
You have to equip
the route, which
means you need to find it,
then put in bolts for where
he can clip in the rope.
This is a massive undertaking.
It can take weeks.
The other aspect is that it's
in a dynamic environment.
Temperature and weather have
a lot of impact on the route.
So Will is racing against time
because as the season warms up,
the route might
not be climbable.
WILL GADD: We've
got two teams of two
working full time
to get it done.
SARAH HUENIKEN: Yeah,
that hold feels sketchy.
Yeah, you got to get
your pick in right.
SARAH HUENIKEN: [GRUNTING]
Any trip you do with Will
is kind of a once in
a lifetime chance.
Let's make as much
progress as we can.
Like, if you're not
psyched to go up, I will.
But I also know that it
can be very dangerous.
And there's a lot of
things we don't control.
And that can be hard to be
his partner-partner in life
and his climbing partner.
But leading up to
it, I saw everything
he did to be ready to climb.
[MUSIC PLAYING]